are you one of the 400,000 people
expected to come to New York for the
Superbowl you not made any lodging
arrangements yet well guess what you are
in luck because everyone it turns out is
looking to cash in on your stay I took
out three different places that you
could hole up in for the big game
starting with this one
a guy's apartment only three miles away
from MetLife Stadium good morning this
is Chris he's listing his two-bedroom
apartment on Airbnb for $1,800 a night
now that might seem pricey but it does
come with leftovers I'm not gonna clean
it out and if they clean it out it's not
the biggest of course the apartment
comes with a super-sized TV and Chris's
killer movie collection I have steel
magnolias I'm sure superbowl people are
hungry oh wow you could really pack it
in yeah yeah you're listening to place
at 1809 you bring ten people here not
that bad I only put it up to three days
ago and I've had five or six inquiries
nobody's committed yet so we'll see I'm
here in Carlstadt New Jersey at the
Econo Lodge just a stone's throw from
MetLife Stadium they have a special
suite that they're hoping to rent $800 a
night let's go take a look all right so
you got your standard fare here nice
leather furniture you got your fridge
microwave combo bathroom Oh
oh yeah a lot of hotels have a jacuzzi
but how many of them have a Jacuzzi in
the bedroom the marble part is only one
of the amenities that you'll have here
at the Econo Lodge there is a sheet
thread-count that measures in the dozens
and the view you have got a beautiful
wholesale frozen fish distributorship
right next door way over on the other
end of the spectrum is the New York
Palace Hotel so this is the living room
it's part of the 5,000 square feet that
make up this suite which by the way goes
for 25 grand a night now if I was just
some ordinary guy I might take this
grand staircase to go upstairs but you
know I'm not going to do that I'm taking
my own private elevator
yep okay I don't want to be
hypercritical here or anything but
where's my marble heart above the bed
where's by jacuzzi in the room where's
the jacuzzi not in the bedroom it's up
on the room so for 25 grand not only do
we get three bedrooms and six bathrooms
you also get something else
your own private limo well come Super
Bowl time you can spend anywhere from
800 to $25,000 a night if you brought
and if you do that's wonderful but most
of us will probably watch the game the
way it was originally intended on our
TVs Hey
you